what's shaking dude
you're looking jacked man yeah
uh so my question uh is
with regards to you know the five people
you surround yourself with
yes sir so
when i was like 18 19 i was getting
really passionate about entrepreneurship
i would hang out no i always called him
like in myself like in my inner self
let's say man these are just
bro dudes like they can't think beyond
like a beer
and then quick sex
and whenever i would try and talk about
like hey don't you want to like do
something
great with your lives you know build a
company start a culture do you know do
something pretty great
they'd kind of like take it as a dick
it's like oh well i'm just gonna
work at my shitty job and like it
so in sum i
i kind of like it's really hard to find
people that are with that same mindset
it's not actually it's not because once
you start
becoming decisive about who you spend
your time with
it makes it easy to spot losers it makes
it easy to spot
anchors and sales in your life you're
still young though right i mean
from what i remember you're in your
mid-20s 23 something like that right
you're still young so i mean that like
that that skill that muscle hasn't
developed yet
i mean i'm i'm in my late 40s like i can
basically look at
a video you know look at somebody's
social feed
click through on their stuff and within
a minute or two
i can tell if they're full of [ __ ] if
they're real yeah okay
like it's it's it's very easy but you'll
get better at it with time and you're
going to get
burned a couple of times and you're
going to spend way too much time with
guys that aren't going to be useful or
that
aren't going to be part of your tribe
that's going to help you level up
in my book there's a chapter on on
higher slow fire quickly did you read
that part
i have not read your book come on
you can't you can't come on here week
after week and not support the channel
man you gotta read the content hold on
i've been i've been reading the other
books you recommended like shoedog and
uh
the amazon story okay finishing up the
amazon your
i'll read your book next i was waiting
for okay okay
higher slow fire fast and all that
really means is
you take your time vetting somebody they
need to earn your trust right there's a
lot of dudes that i've given my trust
away
very very quickly too oh yeah you know
this guy seems like a good guy's
intentions are good especially in the
manual swap right oh yeah you know this
guy's a good guy
you know his intentions seem good boy
was i wrong more than once
um so
like vet them slowly right they want to
bring you in they want to bring you in
tight they want to use your good name
they want to use
some like people want [ __ ] from you when
people want [ __ ] from you very quickly
you have to ask yourself why
right because really really successful
guys that
are serious and have positive intent
on doing good for themselves and the
world lead with that
right they lead with something to give
right so
one of the things that i get a lot of is
people will like message me and they'll
be like
hey you know can you mentor me or you
know can i buy you dinner or a coffee
and pick your brain sort of thing
it's like right away they're leading
with gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
right but if i'm the one doing that like
to someone that i find interesting it's
like hey i would like to buy you dinner
okay so how do you do things okay so
what you lead with
is you take so i did this back when i
was um
focused on entrepreneurs in cars and
interviewing guys and doing stuff like
um
car reviews and i found some of the like
i
basically isolated the the top three
youtube channels
that had the biggest audience with the
most views with the guys that i liked
the most
and i took a look at their channel i
took a look at their website
i took a look at their social feed and
there was things that i spotted that
were sitting in their blind spots
that needed to get fixed maybe a link
was broken maybe there was a better way
for them to offer something
and then i messaged the guy and i said
hey man i know you get a lot of messages
big fan of your work i see these two or
three
um you know potential problems here's
you know here's the solutions to them
you know with the links
also i'd love to you know collab with
you at some point in the future
i got a response from everybody because
i led with
here's me helping you would that be
first
do you think that would be a strong
method like i'm doing my own
entrepreneurship thing i'm
learning code so i can code my own
application so let's say it's there and
i'm like okay
i have it what now i would imagine using
that sort of method would be a decent
way to help them and then
possibly maybe get something in return
maybe publicity
in some sort of fashion um i'm not sure
what you mean by the coding stuff
because i'm not uh
i'm terrible with that sort of stuff i'm
creating a business that's an
application that serves the financial
markets
okay and what you're asking around that
and i would imagine would i use that
method to like let's say look for broken
links at a
influencer and then say okay if if
that's the best angle that
you know that you can find you know to
to work with them then use that like
um tim ferriss in the four-hour work
week talks about how he got involved you
know silicon valley and he was basically
working at a non-profit donating his
time for free living at his
mom's minivan now he's one of the
biggest names out there i think he's got
one of the biggest podcasts definitely
you know the top three or five like he's
up there with joe rogan and stuff like
that so
you you have to lead with giving some
something to somebody
like there's there's just so many guys
out there that lead with take take take
you know give me give me give me like
you owe me something it's like dude i
don't owe you [ __ ]
i don't know you i don't owe you right
and that's one of the biggest lessons
that guys haven't learned today
because you know as a function of
society and the troph you know
participation trophy generation and we
bubble wrap everybody and parents
helicopter them and they can't do
anything wrong you know like
kids haven't learned you know the
necessities of
this virtue so the best thing that you
can do when it comes to this business
project is
stay away from the losers anybody that's
an anchor
find you know people that are sales
is your is your business throwing off
money right now like is it profitable
no i am developing it right now so it's
it's like uh i've been literally doing
it for months i learned java
and every single night like clockwork i
get off work go to the gym
code till midnight and then do it all
over again i've been doing that for
months
so when you get to your first revenue
events and you're starting to make
profit
the first thing that you need to start
to do once you've once you've started to
make money people start to say
lebowski i like what you do you offer
value take my money
right once you start to accumulate that
and you're looking at your bank balance
and it's going up thirty thousand
dollars a month
eighty thousand dollars next month and
you're throwing off all this kind of
profit
as soon as you have profit coming in
then you need to reinvest in yourself
and you can buy yourself a seat in
better rooms
so you sign up for conferences you sign
up for trade organizations
you look for mentors you know and then
you
buy yourself a position or a seat in
that room or you buy yourself a place in
that organization like
the initiation fee for me to get into
entrepreneur's org was something like
four thousand dollars
and then there's various fees you know
along the way and you know there is a
conference
you know that you pay eight thousand
dollars to go to there's a there's a
friend in the network that runs his own
conference and the ticket for that's
eight thousand dollars and you got your
flight in your hotel and you all of a
sudden you know
before you know it maybe you're spending
30 grand a year on personal development
it's all a write-off
and you would say the point of doing
that is to put yourself in a seat with
other people that are
could possibly never forget if you're
the smartest guy in the room you're in
the wrong room sometimes you need to buy
admission to better rooms right right
so if you have a business that that
qualifies for you becoming
lo like for you like a guy like you
should aim to get into eoa
like eoa is entrepreneurs accelerator
organization
um the minimum qualifier from from what
i remember last was 250 000
a year in annual sales so as soon as
you've got a business that does
a quarter million dollars in annual
sales you can sign
up and they give you a free mentor
there's of course cost of admission to
get into it it's probably like 2500
bucks or something like that
they give you a mentor which you meet
with on a monthly basis with usually two
other guys
there's quarterly learning events with
the big dogs
and then you start to network and you
start to learn is it just canada or is
it like national no it's worldwide dude
yeah it's worldwide like there's
something like i don't know 30 30 000
members around the world or something
like that it's huge
it's massive um but yeah that's that's
really how it goes
now before you go we have a question
here
did you ditch the girlfriend yet or you
know more specifically did you have the
threesome
yeah uh so it is the most difficult
thing uh for me
anyways because like there will be
it's really it's really difficult to get
it to be her idea
you know that that's how kind of like
it's not her idea it's your right yeah
it's pretty much my idea
and it's impossible to flip that
narrative yeah there was like a perfect
opportunity like everything
didn't have blonde hair black hair smoke
show still
and she was like hitting on me at the
gym and my girl
my girlfriend was just in the corner
just witnessing the entire thing and she
was like
well her nose is too big or well she she
was wearing
uh lululemon and i don't like girls in
lulu women likes
so there's always going to be like
that's why i told you dude you have to
let her sort through it
and then narrow it down to a couple and
then you get to pick the one
yeah it's it's uh that that part
is i i think she's she uh the
idea of of sharing
is very hard to uh
she's either down for it or she's not
down for it don't force it on her
yeah i i yeah all right cool
um update me once you got some growth
going on you know with the business you
got some traction i want to hear a
little bit more about how you're doing
later on down the road all right
right on oh all right there's still a
long road in terms of
building the thing uh you'd be surprised
how quickly things start to move once
you start getting some traction the the
the the entire purpose of a business
like like don't forget this
the fiduciary duty is to return a profit
to the shareholder
okay but you always have to remember
that
while that is important the value has to
lead all of that
because at the end of the day the
customer can fire the ceo
you know if enough customers get
together they can literally fire a cd
ceo by choosing to spend their money
somewhere else by choosing to spend
their money on a better product
or a superior product so what was the
point to like
serve the customer like customers always
right sort of deal
make a profit make sure it's not a hobby
because a lot of dudes like create these
businesses and
they turned out being hobbies you ever
watched like dragon's den or sharks tank
yeah i just watched shark tank yeah so
you ever see those guys that show up and
they're like i've been running this
business for seven years and it's still
not turning a profit and i need to
get 250 thousand dollars yeah and kevin
o'leary says [ __ ] that
this is not a business this is a hobby
kill it right
so one has to make a profit and two
value make sure the value is big
right because that's because that's
where the hyper growth comes from
big value big big value equals big hyper
growth
got it right all right man see you soon
yeah okay peace
you